i'm a physics teacher i got to do this
okay so i've been going around the
country teaching everybody what's
happened to our election
this is the truth resonating
in america
we uh we totally lost everywhere
was stolen they believe
it and they are acting we got teams all
over the country coming alive
and we are taking this country back
[Applause]
all right we are back guys
it was the the entire uh the entire
internet just dropped
it couldn't be at the worst possible
time so we're back and hopefully it's
all going to uh
things will all keep keep going this guy
was just presenting what he claims is
some mathematical case for why
everything was stolen from donald trump
so it seems like that's sort of the
theme of the rally they've mentioned
mike pillow and uh this guy's talking
about
supposed math and this type of thing so
it does seem as though um that is going
to be the gist
and there goes that guy
is i think that's marjorie taylor green
right there i don't know is that her
right there do you guys see that
that does seem to be marjorie taylor
green
so all sorts of trouble with this right
side broadcasting
feed just bizarre
it's a it's a gig of yikes yeah exactly
it's all extremely hard to believe
so in any case we're back on every on
everything
um and we're standing by for donald
trump at the top of the hour
now i had a whole bunch of super chats
that i wanted to get to and they
disappeared because we had to reset the
stream which i apologize about
that's a horrible horrible thing but uh
i think we are basically back up and
running now which is a really great
thing
yeah this is in ohio it seems that this
is part of basically the grievance tour
that is continuing uh with donald trump
and and his associates
and affiliates so i don't expect
uh too much other than that
let's take a listen i think this is now
marjorie taylor green yeah let's take a
look
there appears to be no audio now from
marjory taylor green
and everything going wrong huh there it
is
what a feed you guys are great
[Applause]
oh i love you ohio i love you
[Applause]
now i always check when i go speak to a
crowd
because i want to make sure i'm talking
to smart
people right it's pretty important
yeah and those are the crowds she avoids
who's your president
[Applause]
oh i love you ohio i love you
[Music]
i always check when i go speak to a
crowd because i want to make
what the hell is going on with this feed
guys
this has been going on all day for long
periods of time the audio just
completely drops out
that's right you know they attacked
president trump
for four years didn't they
they did everything they could
they had their fake russian collusion
conspiracy
theory witch hunt they have the dirty
rotten
media tell lies almost every single day
and the democrats schemed and schemed
anything
to stop our great president trump they
went skiing
america first but she knows something
he did it anyway didn't he
[Applause]
they were skiing that's weird how
elitist
well you know there's a new bad guy in
washington d.c
her name is congresswoman marjorie
taylor greene
i think they don't like me for the very
same reasons
they didn't like president trump you're
both idiots yeah that's true
i love you too and you know that's a
badge of honor i'll wear
i have no problem with it i didn't go to
washington dc to make friends
i didn't go there to join the club
you want to know where i went
yeah to drain the swamp
proud of our idiocy
[Applause]
but now i have the radical democrat
socialists the fake news media the
silicon
valley cartel name one socialist
republicans trying to take me out
are you gonna let that happen i hope
no because here's what's going on and
they're scared to death
we're doing this all over the country
[Applause]
doing what but i have a great big
red target on my back i do
you want to know why because you're an
idiot in the halls of congress
every single day i'm fighting for you
[Applause]
america
now let me give you just a few reasons
why the dc
swamp hates me so much
because i want to impeach joe biden
marjorie taylor green has the unique
combination
of being both one of the most ignorant
people to ever come to power
and someone with a completely bankrupt
moral code
and when you put those things together
it's pretty bad
and i want to fire dr anthony fauci
case in point fire doctors
you know there's a lot of people that
need to be fired
did you hear that tony they want you
locked up
lock up doctors yeah there's an idea why
not
reminds me of pretty bad things
you guys are awesome i tell you what
washington dc cannot connect with real
america
they have no idea how you think and feel
yeah real america is people willing to
stand out there for 10 hours waiting for
the former president to speak to them
which is what
some of these people have been doing
minority in washington dc
and uh the democrats are running the
country or they're not running their
country and we really have no i
no idea what they're doing i don't think
biden knows what he's doing
does he
do people want to listen to this or do
you want me to read and answer uh super
chats because i have i have a bunch of
super chats whatever people want trump's
probably coming on in about 20 minutes
now the phone's ringing bringing ways
into law by federalizing our elections
we aren't going to allow that
now biden has weaponized the doj
unbelievable
so he can go after trump supporters
while at the same time
ignoring antifa blm domestic
terrorist does that make any sense
if it were true do you guys think any of
those riots we saw
all year long were peaceful protests
no no they were domestic terrorists
is she talking about the january 6th
riots oh no she's not
there's looting our stores private
businesses
killing people and rampaging terrorizing
our country
but as trump supporters thereafter
don't forget they hate you because you
love president trump
now while democrats are ripping our
country apart
with racist critical race theory
does that even make any sense yeah okay
let me read a few of the super chats
because this this is pretty weaponized
um
let's see what we've got here glad the
stream looping cat was identified and
removed
sir you should have bought rudy's title
insurance to protect the stream
from freud he always has the goofiest
lineup of your show
glad you're back glad you're well the
ohio legislators are trying to pass a
bill to make it illegal to film cops
not surprised are they going to attack
the capital again
i fear that they are in august or
september or whenever it is that this is
now supposedly happening
how much will this boost cover numbers i
guess you mean covet numbers
it probably won't it's outdoors it's
outdoors there should be a mental health
test for candidates i'd fail but hell at
least we wouldn't have this thing
robert brunswick says glad i got you
back again so glad you're well it's
getting
it's odd getting a cold out of the blue
as my son and i have i did not go to a
doctor
okay thank you keep us posted on that
probably will go away on its own
my mom could beat her up my cousin is at
the clan rally
john mckinney says if republicans win
the midterms do you think they
investigate biden
biden and kamala nonstop including
fouchy's emails
yeah probably probably this scares me
because i fear this may cost dems in
2024 just like how hillary's emails cost
hillary in 2016.
yeah i think we should not understate
the importance of the 22 midterms
and 40 ounce asking how is green still
in congress well you get two years you
get two years and so she is still uh
still part of that let's see what i can
do
um from the standpoint of
brightness because i'm i'm very much
aware uh
of what's going on with my back lighting
it should sort of improve but let me see
if i can do
just a little bit more brightness maybe
a little bit more gamma
there we go and then maybe later even a
little more omega
yeah no it's all it's all pretty strong
um
thanks to dranoa for the super chat sir
is your view count skyrocketing downward
yes
exactly we've tested very positively
from the standpoint of negative and
that's really exciting
if you're just joining us we are
standing by for donald trump in ohio we
don't know what to expect
let me make sure i thank everybody who's
been supporting the stream i want to say
thanks to short brief
black white rook fatty mcblunts
as well as astrolycos
harry kiss my toe beans
whoa pink and blonde
another sobe and sock queen
that's nine total putting us at 15.
we also have a one day membership
special it's
sad trump the reason for that is
this entire trump thing has really
gotten pretty sad like you know doing a
rally
you're not running for anything at this
point it's basically just like
an ego boost rally so we've got a one
day coupon code
sad trump because i'm out of state
i am going to take the risk of telling
you how big of a discount it is
it's 70 and normally i wouldn't do that
but
because we're across state lines i'm
comfortable saying it it is a 70
discount the code is sad trump all one
word
wow look at these right wingers there's
people dumping
50 and 100 super chats on right side
broadcasting
just just dump after dump it's crazy
um okay so in any case yeah
everybody who uh i i will be i should be
able to thank absolutely everybody who
uses that code okay let's see what else
we've got as far as super chats go
comedy gold best wishes from scotland
david welcome yes thank you
thanks for what you do says shane david
have you ever seen the show it's always
sunny in philadelphia you remind me of
dennis reynolds i've actually not seen
that
i just finished watching counterpart
great show
with jk simmons just started season two
of
lupe fantastic show
my best bet is green will be primaried
but i don't see the seat flipping i
agree
junie says 2010 was death panels 14 was
sharia lore 2018 was migrant caravans
2022 is critical race theory
it seems the gop just sticks to fear and
not policy
yes robert brunswick
says yes sir both doing fine now ben
says marsha marjorie taylor green
lindsey graham shapiro and jenner all
have the same
pronoun it its i don't know that i like
that
risperidone rudy says massive member
dump caused florida building collapse i
don't like that at all
the florida building collapse is
horrible wizard of froboz
says no public acknowledgement spend
time on something more educational
wizard you're under no obligation to be
here my friend
i say that with complete and total peace
and love
complete and total peace and love um
all right let's see who this is is this
is this ron descent no who is that i
can't tell who that is
is it jim acosta
i'll tell you it's amazing to look out
here and see
so many wonderful americans thank you
all for being here today
listen so the weaponization continues
and uh
and and we'll we'll keep watching it um
as we get closer and closer to the start
of this
wacky and completely wild event also big
thank you to justin
andrew watson as well as real time fan
i appreciate the two twitch subs guys uh
very
very much appreciate that um
people saying the coupon code isn't
working no it definitely is the coupon
code is absolutely working
and it's it's never really worked as
strongly as it is today
um okay the democratic brotherhood of
saint nicholas says if any members of
congress had died on january 6th
do you think the senate would have voted
to convict him what is the final
line trump couldn't cross i fear
that there is no final line that trump
couldn't cross people asking for
subtitles sure
i think that quite frankly there is no
line that trump couldn't cross
and i mean i think you know the fact
that we keep going to these wackier and
wackier
scenarios uh to try to imagine a
situation where trump
would finally be held accountable um
i i i think that that's indicative of
how bad it has gone
okay our super chats disappeared there
all right they're still good super chats
are there very strongly all right i want
to say a huge thank you to
roger strip matter roger just signed up
on my website with the coupon code
sad trump it's a one day coupon code
we are either celebrating or or
bemoaning
the fact that trump is such a sad guy
that he had to hold a rally for himself
it's sort of like a
pay attention to me kind of event i'm
very curious what he'll say about 2024
i'm very curious uh what he will say is
he going to go
full in on biden dementia for example
what we'll know momentarily we will know
momentarily
and significant interest in this over a
hundred thousand people
right now right wingers watching on the
right side
broadcasting network and it is
self-indulgent
it is low energy it's a lot of things
we've come to expect from trump
and if you look at the chat that's
happening on right side broadcasting
people saying trump won just straight up
trump won
not not even equivocating in any way
whatsoever so it's it's pretty sad stuff
uh no doubt about it okay let me get to
a few other super chats
serge says albert jordan klepper is at
that rally
ali says it's a diverse crowd i've
spotted 15 different types of bigots
[Laughter]
that's good i like that ollie that's a
that's a good one and then another super
chat from gt
um which i will see momentarily
um oh it looks like there are actually
some of my viewers that are invading the
right side broadcasting chat
this actually happened last time we
looked at an event that was being
broadcast exclusively by right side
broadcasting where
people started sending super chats
relating to
you know felony 21 coupon codes and
these types of things
right now they're not reading super chat
so there would be no point in doing that
but it does seem as though we are doing
a little bit of brigading
in the uh in the chat and i love that i
love that and
they have built a very big audience
there so that is not uh that is not a
bad thing
a couple other questions gt says from
your knowledge has there ever been a
more unhinged political group in the
united states politics than mega q
oh man you know it's possible that there
have been but they were relatively small
um you know in in the in the early 19th
century
you know there could have been small
groups yeah i think i think the answer
is maybe
but not one with the power or at least
following that maga q has at this point
in time lily says the crowd looks small
thanks for all you do david can you talk
about possible trump organization
indictment coming next week
you know we have talked about it a bunch
of times the trump org indictment might
be next week
the matt gates indictment might be in
the next few weeks
at this point it's just wait and see i
don't know what else to say about it
quite frankly um it's just a matter of
uh
let's see what happens and then we will
comment for
for uh for sure for sure i want to say
thank you to
hobo spidey who just signed up via
twitch prime and his new member number
19
today also want to thank uh
oh hold on a second what was this
i want to say thank you to scott
rutherford who just signed up with the
coupon code
sad trump we do have you know as i've
said before
really the best way to support what we
do is to get a membership on my website
usually these discount codes are so
extreme
that the blue states i can't even say
how big the
discount is because these blue states
they'll send their attorney general
sci vance will be all over me because
i'm currently in florida
i'm comfortable telling you that the
coupon code sad trump
is a 70 off code it's just an insane
number
in the same number and uh that works on
the website scott rutherford taking
advantage of it
and a number of other people all very
excited to be here
clearly um yeah ice
jonathan i see oh okay here we go
wizard says all i meant is i didn't want
to detract from your show to hear my
name said i'm there oh i'm sorry wizard
wizard i uh i take it back i i apologize
i thought you were attacking me
and so i reacted and i attacked you and
nobody was attacking anybody nobody was
attacking anybody i appreciate you being
here
jonathan says will joe biden had
trump arrested since he
president the answer is no the answer is
no
presidential nurse says all these
republicans who fed the big lie
should face a huge primary challenge
absolutely
absolutely john says did you hear about
the good guy with a gun that got shot
and killed by law enforcement after he
shot a gunman
it's the world republicans want i did
hear about that
and you know i have been talking about
that for a really long time and
you know you you really just think
if these people would just think if your
instinct is to believe that a situation
that's
already chaotic and violent would be
better served by
more civilians with guns so that when
police show up
it's even more chaotic we simply have a
difference of opinion
about what logic is it's that simple
and that story it's a sad story it's a
tragic story
but it's exactly what i've been saying
for a long time you know the one that
people were saying it after was
the aurora colorado batman movie theater
shooting
and there were people saying you know if
there were that was a gun-free zone
the movie theater said no guns allowed
if you had more people with guns there
it would have been better
really more people with guns in a dark
movie theater that would have made the
situation better
give me a break guys come on come on get
off my stream if that's your belief
okay other super chats coming in be
careful desantis ordered the ag to
investigate you
yeah you know we actually we host our
website
in malta so that when desantis tries to
take me down for
illegal coupon codes we just say
jurisdictionally desantis you've got
nothing
kim says i'm in the crowd right now
thousand or more people are here all
hate here all saying he won and stopped
steal kim is that true are you really at
that event
that's interesting if true alvaro says
it's been 20 years since the dream act
was introduced by durbin
dems failed to pass it with a 60 super
majority biden immediately grants tps
status to venezuelans
why can't dems ever vote for our base
voters
i agree with you it must be done
andrew says the rally is 35 miles away
from me in cleveland it's too close for
comfort i
i understand that ray says your genuine
laugh made me laugh thank you
no thank you ray i appreciate that
uh let's see what else we've got here
i need to say whoa
whoa we just got a huge membership dump
here hold on a second
look at this sergio angiano
just signed up with the code sad trump
tim carnell new member with code
sad trump jen forshi
using the coupon code daniel gonzalez
signing up with
sad trump joshua frappier
coupon code sad trump that's five
heidi de bellis using the code
we're gonna get arrested travis simmons
using the code sad trump this is this is
too much
andrew souza using the code sad trump
that's eight
oh my god desantis is coming for me
jason pooley signing up with the code is
number nine
danielle dantzler using the coupon code
sad trump
and greg glazer using the coupon code
said trump
that is 11 putting us at 31
whoa clearly resonating with people
also want to say thank you to dinan cleo
kyoko and lovely ladybug
for the twitch prime subs putting us at
34.
um what is happening here
what is hap that must be bot activity
there's no way around it guys
i believe that this is jim shorts jordan
yeah let's take a look at what's
happening here
and this the speed going down again
here we go signs we've went from peace
in the middle east to rockets being
fired on our best friend and ally the
state of israel
has nothing to do with what else they're
trying to do raise
your taxes when president trump was in
office
we were guys i can assure you
the people at this rally are not getting
their taxes raised by joe biden
that we can say with almost complete and
total certainty
contrast president trump did
more of what he said he would do than
any president in my lifetime
that's hard to believe you unless you're
i tell
i tell folks all the time we make this
job way too complicated
what did you tell me here's all the
voters you were gonna do
go do that if they elect you they put
confidence in you
what a disaster send you to go to
congress or whatever office you're
guys i'd i'd go to another feed i just
don't think there is another feed
i think this is the only feat people in
the chat on right side broadcasting are
also complaining it's it's pretty bad
this is weaponized streaming
man
he did it right get out of the iran deal
we did
said he put the embassy in jerusalem he
did said he bring hostages home from
north korea he did
and on and on to go
wow what a contrast
and that's why you're all here that's
why you're all here because you want him
to run again
in 2024 so do i
[Applause]
wow
wow and there it goes black
what is going on with this feed huh i
mean it's like obviously it's
not my connection that it goes black we
still have graphics a couple months ago
in one week
and that keeps happening where they'll
it'll go black
and then come back from this angle
almost like they're they're resetting in
some way i don't even know what's going
on
if you remember this week the week ended
with the trial judge in minneapolis
admonishing maxine waters for the
ridiculous things she said
while the jury was deliberating and in
between those two events
the democrats in the house passed
legislation to make d.c
estate so they could get two new u.s
senators
and the very next day they introduced
legislation
to put four new associate justices on
the supreme court to pack the court
all in six days if that doesn't
underscore how crazy the left has
so there's jim jordan yeah and it looks
like trump is probably in the process of
arriving there seems to be more sort of
like security bro
activity going on and also looks like a
bunch of fire trucks behind
jim jim shorts so um
yeah it we must be getting ready to go
pretty soon
let's look at a few other super chats
coming in here
um where did i leave off
please mention the hot air balloon crash
in new mexico daughter and son-in-law
waiting to hear
from their friend who's a pilot i didn't
hear about it julie but best wishes to
everybody
um just woke up to find the tangerine
terror is back
which hibernation was a thing for humans
hi from the philippines
what is the official wine of the event i
need to be i think it would be boxed
wine right
for something like this what type of
razors do you use
some kind of german um you know safety
razor type thing just a basic
basic razor i just became a member here
on youtube
beautiful dana ferguson says trump
promised if he lost we'd never hear from
him again
trump lied shocker well trump doesn't
think he lost
trump doesn't think he lost that's what
you have to remember
jay bundy says wanted to donate back
some of that sweet sad
trump money i just saved yeah thank you
did you have to fill out a political
questionnaire upon entering florida
is also it's insane these politicians
can just blatantly lie yes they can
yes they can um andrew says thanks for
the code
i can afford to support thanks to the
code oh yes thank you andrew
from the standpoint of medical is trump
on stimulants
couldn't tell you couldn't tell you
let me thank just a couple more people
uh
whoa is this even legal
thanks to emily cavuati stephen
charbondale jay bundy jessica thomas
mel's van wyes vincent
schulten maybe i can't tell hilario
avena
robbie rash anna corral stephen thompson
kelly miller michael page
michael catalan alexander
uh hold on alexander rozin
dibusi bano i i apologize i butchered
that and
john booten or bhutan that is
putting us at 47. we do have a one day
only coupon code because of what's going
on today that code is
sad trump all one word i'm doing the
best i can with the names guys i'm doing
the best i can
the code is sad trump and you can use it
on my website also thanks via twitch to
david
digit i hope that's the right
pronunciation jiu-jitsu
and uh bass bass amandeep and
archer blue christalms jeez
i have a feeling some of these may not
be legal names
that's just my instinct though
um okay
jonathan sending a super chat to all the
robots across the galaxy
david have you ever considered
partnering with namco to do a pac-man
pac-man crossover i think it's a gold
mine with unlimited potential
chris i've never thought of that please
set it up for me if you can
i would absolutely love to do that tommy
says yes or no prediction on whether
melania comes to the event
there is no way melania comes to this
event i would bet
almost anything melania is not coming to
this event
at this point the gop has devolved into
a domestic terrorist organization
the video is frozen as you can see guys
this is not me the names at the bottom
are still scrolling
there you go upper trump or downer trump
i believe today it will be upper trump
is it worse to be racist or to traffic
and racism as a grift i think they're
they're equivalent the impact on the
public is the same
but that's a good question jeff oh
people saying downer trump i think it's
i think it's upper trump
i really think it's upper trump today
let's listen to a little bit more we
have some
good friends in the uh in the dayton
area and they invited us
to come down to dinner the summer time
of year and they said
we're gonna go to daryl we said sure
we're we're free we can we can do that
we made chicken pop
dear god and here it goes great we we
like history and learning about
buildings and these yeah
he likes learning about buildings all
right so let me see if i can switch i'm
going to try to find the other stream
hey the lady at the door people saying
see spinning they take you on a tour
of this home where these families
amazing americans
lived and grew up and did their things
and you learn all kinds of neat things
about these guys
you know the bicycle shop the things
they built the things they tinkered with
and
see spam and it's a great tour but on
the last
room it's one of the uh brothers
bedrooms
one of the brothers they tell you a few
more things about this particular right
brother
not seeing it on season and then they
finish by showing you two pictures let's
try newsmax first picture they hold up
that first flight 1903 kitty hawk north
carolina
in this thing and you look at it and
your first thought is wow how'd that
thing ever get off the ground
they do and the truth is it barely did
they don't have um they don't have jim
jordan they're they're doing this
they're monitoring i guess we can go
with this it does seem
like this is a better quality stream i
appreciate that that's a good idea
okay let me look at a few other super
chats here
um we appreciate you david
instead of politics let's talk
sandwiches what are your top three minor
ban me philly cheesesteak and croc
monsieur be well oh no
so for me bon me is a top sandwich
um i think the the reuben is a top
sandwich
the rachel is a top sandwich um
what's our other top soon argentinian
sandwiches amiga
are up very very high
um yeah there's lots of sandwiches
if the gop wins 22 will they impeach
biden for ukraine and fauci for wuhan
if you think the gop cares whether
they're a smoking gun or not i got a
bridge to sell you
right david i will be monitoring any
changes to your home
title while you're on vacation you can
enjoy yourself with peace of mind
yeah you know i actually got an
insurance that rudy giuliani offers
which if anybody tries to steal your
home title
uh it covers that sir i'm starting to
worry that our fearless leader trump may
not return to office in 2021 any words
of comfort for those awaiting patiently
i do not have any no you're going to
have to keep waiting
i guess his bone spurs aren't hurting
today
david seeley says thanks for taking the
time to stream on vacation
sir check out lukali pizza in south
beach
marsha betger says jared and ivanka
aren't coming either no they seem to be
alienated from trump
this is tangential but have you seen the
phenomenon by james fox i have not
dax alvarez says something i can't quite
see yet
um oh my god there's more speakers
who is this guy i also want to say thank
you to
uh oh no i guess nobody else
oh wait now let me go to my other screen
oh another huge bunch of i want to say
thanks to jessica edwards
jamie lloyd whoa oh hold on a second
jessica edwards jamie lloyd
signing up with the coupon code sad
trump if you're just joining
us we are awaiting donald trump in
wellington
ohio we don't know what he's going to
talk about we don't know
anything about what to expect other than
it will probably be unhinged
um because this is so sad and depressing
we have a one day code on my website sad
trump all one word all lower case few
dozen people have taken advantage of it
it's just because this is all very sad
this entire event is to feed trump's ego
or his eggo as some like to say in
certain circles
um and so you can use that code today
only
just you know maybe use a fake name when
you sign up so you don't get
indicted for such a big discount it is a
70
discount code which is just wacky
okay um
other super chats
all right people liking san luis obispo
yeah of course
found a clean stream on fox 32 oh no no
no fox is very litigious we can't do
that
david the youtube channel fox 32 yeah no
we're not doing that
nothing like the dying utterances of
uneducated white working-class voters
in decaying states who can't accept the
world is changing love it
that's basically what this is yeah let's
listen to a guy
built a beautiful wall to secure our
southern
border never happened
that's right annie ended the disastrous
catch and release policy
which forced lar law enforcement to dump
criminals
into your country laurel
that's weird and for the first time in
four years guess what guys
this country the united states of
america was
energy independent
sadly we've quickly gone from america
first
common sense to joe biden's america
last nonsense
whoa it's a big clown
honestly joe biden's disastrous first
few months
would be a little less bad if they
weren't for the fact
that we have republicans like anthony
gonzalez who continued to betray us
in washington d.c the rhino
approach
exactly the media wants to focus on how
he supported nancy pelosi
and her sham impeachment
that is a betrayal he can never turn
back from
and that he should have to answer to day
after day
after day you guys see this guy right
who just stood up for a second this is
this is actually the the code i
created the code sad trump earlier but
this does have a very sad feel i mean
it's like the
it's people who were uh soundly defeated
um who can't accept that
who just are now having a party to sort
of like pretend that
they're still running i guess for
something or in the running for
something it's bizarre
um whoa hold on a bunch of other uh
oh look at this will sasso the great
actor will
sasso coming in with a super chat i
can't see what will said yet
but we will have to wait and see thank
you for your important work david guys
we we have a celebrity visitor today
what a this please mark the day down my
friends
uh great to see will here that's
fantastic
um a few other super chats we'll get
back to that we'll get back to that
um how do you keep your head from
exploding helmets
i guarantee he'll mention critical race
theory david i loved it when you had
little back and forths with sam
cedar would you be open to doing more
videos sure yeah
do you agree blue is the best color more
specifically periwinkle blue no cerulean
i would go with
killing me small says it looks like
trump's there to endorse max miller
currently at the podium
whoa
apparently the current congressman in
the state voted for trump's impeachment
50 50 odds of upper downer trump will
the adderall cocaine win over the xanax
and benzos place your bets
there is will sasso people in the chat
loving will sasso
and referring to him as sir some people
saying will sasso 2024
um
okay you just tricked me someone just
said my this microphone's not plugged in
it is plugged in you guys got me you
guys got me
yeah it's plugged in and then if i press
the button you'll see i'm muted
it's plugged in as evidenced by the fact
that when i press mute
it mutes okay thank you
um
david what do you think about bitcoin
adoption in el salvador and paraguay
what is the btc discount code for
pacman.com for the sandwiches
the only code right now is sad trump
that's the only code and uh ron desantis
just signing up for a membership
whoa ron desantis investigating
you you guys want to know something
really funny actually
that's obviously a joke once we were
investigating gold line
the gold company that glenn beck used to
promote
and word got back to the gold blind ceo
and i saw a new membership come across
and it was really the guy
and later we got a call from goldline's
lawyer like you'd think the gold blind
ceo would be smart enough
to create the membership under a fake
name but no
but no but let me say thank you to
sherry nettles
ron desantis amy williams
joseph j wait hold on a second is amy
williams from uh
evanescence are these all fake names
sherry nettles ron desantis amy williams
joseph jefferson martha carnahan
lawrence keana wiley
uh robert brunswick will sasso
doreen mcguire amy rentool well
memberships are just dumping in
kim norton mary haley
that's 12. 12 53 hold on 3 plus 2 is 5.
nothing to carry 1 plus 5 is 6.
that's 65 right god i hope so this math
is getting complimented
uh okay other super chats coming in
nina says sending love with oh i missed
nina hold on where'd that go
sending love without trump i don't need
to watch obsessively the news now
buck says and you know it's will sasso
because who would pretend to be will
sasso
hugs and kisses that's i'm finding that
a little bit rude buck
jonathan says did they find the oranges
of corvid
they did how likely is it trump's health
prevents a run in 24 when he no longer
has doctors sneaking cauliflower into
his mashed potatoes
i think when i think about why trump
might not run in 24
health is one of the top things for sure
david sur one could argue some of the
contemporary conclusions drawn from
critical race theory are reductive but i
don't see how the theory itself is
you know i've done so much on crt lately
i don't feel like doing more now
very bright background did god take you
already take care david
yes thank you david can you say this
trump rally is so
not pog what's your favorite ice cream
flavor a pistachio
and uh cherry chocolate
chunk yeah didn't know what critical
race theory was until the outrage
trump has emboldened some and opened
some eyes
so not all bad um
maybe it's not sure about that
not sure about that okay here is jenna
ellis
she is maybe the only person suspected
of contracting covid through flatulence
so remember rudy giuliani dropping four
bombs on her
during a michigan event and then she
tested positive
still the we want it needs to be
evidence-based we're still studying it
for sure um
i know guy i know i'm behind i need to
say thank you to a couple of other
people
we are very close to hearing from trump
i want to say thanks to matzo ball soup
as well as bob strakely
kelly enemo
tiny hedgehog thomas o'neal
all of whom just signed up using the
coupon code sad trump
we are we are moments from hearing from
donald trump
and we have a one day code on my website
sad trump because this is so sad guys a
fully grown man at least in the physical
sense donald trump
is holding a rally for himself it's sort
of like a consolation party
i mean i don't know how else to describe
it it's like a consolation party
he lost everything he lost the 2018
house for republicans what are these
people doing
amy uh one of the other issues obviously
the border situation because
obviously one of the other issues um
it's all just
so so sad and so today only you can get
a
70 zero percent discount
at joinpakman.com with the coupon code
sadtrump
and 70 people have already uh dropped
memberships in
uh many under pseudonyms including names
like ron desantis
but we appreciate it all we appreciate
it all other super chats coming in sir
how is the garden the garden is doing
really really well
really really well my my uh snow
snap peas snow peas have all done well
um are they having are they having
technical issues let's see
administration to allow the floodgates
to
open and then for them to pretend that
they actually
want to keep it looks like scrump will
be speaking soon
for people who missed the start of the
stream i am in florida
first thing that happened is i got into
a lift
and the driver said uh
sir where are you going and no but then
i i
said yeah i know people coming to
florida to get vaccinated it seems great
there's so many vaccines around
and the driver said to me uh i'm not
getting vaccinated
i said really why and he said because my
mom got
vaccinated and after her second dose her
body became
magnetic um keys were sticking to her
and i said you know that's not true
right like
and this was all in spanish by the way
also it was a cuban guy
we the conversation took place in
spanish i said you know that's not true
right
just imaginary and he said uh
ccc me mama you know it went on and on
and
i changed the topic i changed the topic
because it was just disgusting
but that's florida for you trump will
receive a
foe 21 gun salute tonight
you can now say you're on the soros
payroll
david are you broadcasting from heaven
yes i am
isn't the u.s screwed the ftp act is
dead and the voter suppression bills are
winning
gop destroyed the mind of half the
country what's the plan
i don't know i don't know
love you on your show so much david
you're a legend that's too much
just joined using the code sad trump
always enjoy your shows between you and
hal
sparks i don't know i would have made
how i would have made it through 2020.
thank you
do windmills really cause cancer i mean
i guess if they're made of asbestos
and you breathe it in right
david space lasers are fake news please
give a shout out to my partner brittany
happy to have you in florida peace and
love from jacksonville peace and love
please peace and love
i honestly have laughed way more at your
right humor on this stream than at any
of stephen crowder's comedy
yeah did you guys know that stephen
crowder is a comedian
like sometimes when steven crowder
dresses up as a woman
it's not only because he's transphobic
it's because he's a comedian
i didn't know that i didn't know that
david are you broadcasting from an
airplane hanger your roo your audio is a
little off yes yes yes
um i'm uh they're getting my king air
350
is just getting a uh the air
conditioning replaced
and so that's all yes that's all that's
happening
by the way if you are just joining us i
should mention the guy on the lower
right is dick morris let's listen to him
just briefly then it's over you turn on
the guy
who was the head of your ticket and you
advocate that he'd be thrown out of
office after
so dick is now engaged in a brutal
battle against his own tongue to put
together a coherent thought
he hung up on me when i interviewed him
so if you're interested in my interview
with dick morris where he hangs up on me
he says
nice interview and he hangs up when i
asked him what we would call a real
question
you can find that on my main youtube
channel
we also have the second youtube channel
up and running
at youtube.com pacmanlive
the best moments from the live streams
show up at the second youtube channel
um youtube.com
pacmanlive dave oh hold on
sand wait wait wait i've missed a bunch
why do american patriots dress like
clowns
i don't know sandy says your audio
sounds roomy and not great you should
hire me to help you with your audio
yeah it's just i'm just at a hotel and
it's you know
my audio is typically pristine but i'm
just in a hotel and i've got a trash
microphone so
that's uh that's the reality david do
you think trump will have his pants on
correctly
uh you know he he wasn't wearing his
pants backwards last time
donald j trump says not happy with the
coupon code david
i know i know i want to say thank you to
marcus valecko micheline beatty
brittany hout ham dip
sha nanigans as well as kevin miles
paul wilson all of whom just signed up
we are now at 77 we are at a fever pitch
here
just moments from donald trump's first
real rally i guess since biden's
inauguration
he did that one under protest uh before
the january fifth
special elections right now i'm not even
sure i recall correctly
um and we are celebrating how gloriously
sad this is by allowing people to sign
up on my website with the coupon code
sad trump all one word you saved 70
i'm allowed to tell you because i'm in
florida and the coupon code is legal in
florida
um and so it's it's a 70
it's crazy sir matzo ball soup checking
in have you updated us on the status of
the garden today
monumentally important much love
enjoying the content yes the garden is
doing fine
david and how sparks were the salvation
of 2020
thank you miranda i appreciate that and
mark
english's super chat uh oh no mark
didn't send
a message i was wondering if you're as
obsessed with and amazed by oans pierce
and sharp as i am i don't know who that
is
i don't know who pearson sharp is
windmill bird funeral sound bites
for your sampler yes there's a super
chat here from
teddy limbrinzio pablo joder leader
nogargo
who says for producer lewis has coveted
again after vaccine
the only way is to end the filibuster in
my opinion
all right very important let's listen
what could they possibly be talking
about candidate
of california joe collins joe in a
superman t-shirt feeling a little super
tonight with this rally going on
well you know right now we're having a
candidate training up in my office
and uh it's a saturday so i was a little
relaxed and uh but you know i threw my
coat on to come down here and speak to
you guys for a second
love it love it you should dress like
that every day i need a t-shirt like
that
so what do you think about the rally
tonight and what do you hope to hear
or not hear uh from the former president
well i think the rally is great it's
good to see the former president uh
trump back at it again
i just got an important alert that the
microphone the reason it sounds roomy
is it's pointed at my ceiling so let's
see
let's just do a mice so wait hold on am
i supposed to talk into this end or the
side can is this better
can anybody tell me
this is better oh wow wow wow wow
okay good excellent
is it actually so like a lot better
that's hilarious
well good i'm glad we were able to do
that
pick you up on that because you're right
that is a great idea and
republicans definitely need to do that
especially when you look at the
divisions
all right it looks like prompt is nearby
let's celebrate the microphone being
fixed
by me uh pronouncing the names of some
new subscribers properly
over on twitch i want to say thank you
to
crystalina campfire brittany's
tobes candies poppin
waniram delams that is
six putting us at 83.
and then on my website people taking
advantage of the one day code
sad trump colin pine paul wilson
oh now hold on just colin pine i thanked
paul wilson already
oh hold on no alan shuler
street justice stephanie cogell
colin pine there we go and now i do
believe that i am caught up
uh perfect and it looks like we're very
very close
to uh trump's arrival how many arrests
will there be at this event i don't know
that's a really good question
is this a super spreader event no
probably not
it's outdoors david can you debate
stephen crowder sure
saw your discussion where you said you
thumbed through moral landscape
but earlier you were emphatic that it
was endlessly fascinating
bummer you're my truth hero so help me
understand
wow i don't know what's going on i don't
know what that means
i just noted trump is rage tweeting the
lower third yeah
um i tried telling you the truth david
say my name
yeah i don't know this name teddy
limbrencio
pablroder leadernogo
sir it would be an honor to meet you in
person
important question entran it's entrance
of course it's international
pearson sharp is a guy at oan who looks
like jim carrey was the mask
oh i do know exactly he also kind of has
a dr oz look yeah i have seen that guy
yeah there's a guy on oan
wait no no no is he on oan or is he on
newsmax
i thought the mass guy was on newsmax
now i'm confused
[Music]
okay mind scramble says
um something i can't quite see it
okay very good
yeah we should be moments from trump
the camera is shaking people are going
completely nuts
is trump's car in the back or something
is that what's going on
because you're not able to project your
voice because you're so frail and old
and weak
i'm not sure what to do about it um i
think that the solution for joe biden
is dick morris talking about his own
voice or joe biden's you know what that
is
they stuff a moose head and put it on
the wall oh my goodness that's what we
need to do
if you're buying stuff oh there's an
ambulance here they must be bringing
trump in on an ambulance okay
totally normal guys completely and
totally normal a few other super chats
that we can get in
really enjoyed your debate with ben
shapiro regarding 2a have you attempted
to debate him again
yes does he duck you he just doesn't
respond
i mean whether that's called ducking or
not i don't know
uh you be the judge of that
a few other new members taking advantage
of the today-only coupon code
sad trump are jeff cannell
megan michaels linda schmidt
and jeanette taylor this could be
an historic day as far as memberships
are concerned in 2021
also want to say thanks to triple ccc
as well as canned caviar for subscribing
on twitch
and gifting one via twitch we're at
94 and that is a wild
number i'm actually getting some reports
that
the website is under such heavy load
from massive membership
dumps that the the website may have gone
down um
the code is working the website is dead
you guys killed it no i'm kidding the
website's fine
the website's fine um and
it seems as though trump has arrived and
we're going to hear
from him very very soon
uh let's listen to dick morris a little
more would be doing the exact opposite
is that the feeling that you get aj
yes i definitely have some concerns you
don't want to stop
stoke the racial fire that is kind of
underneath
uh everything right now even teams which
i think was a positive thing and
something that trump actually wanted to
do
previously uh we've got to stick
together and i hope to hear trump
talking about
how he wants to come back and bring the
country together more
because we need that so much right now
and it's not just racial divisions it's
like
people just becoming separated by
everything
you know right like for example the
people who
think the vaccine magnetizes you are
struggling to get along with people that
understand science
that's too bad but it's also very much
understandable
uh other super chats coming in perfect
job you said it very strongly
david the problem with windmills is they
make that sound
very bad for property values i know
what's a more heated sports
rivalry brazil argentina or red sox
yankees
i'd say brazil argentina yeah
nothing creative sending a bunch of
super chats with no message that's okay
we we welcome all
it looks i mean it something must be
happening here right
this is in ohio uh many places in ohio
um have very late sunsets
in the summer because it is the western
edge of the eastern time zone
for those uh wondering
i guess there's still more light there
than here yeah
right i would say so
okay good larry cuartowitz says he's
definitely at oan he did a covid special
when the death count was at 250 k and
broke down how only 14
000 were actually from the virus right
right okay yeah yeah the guy who looks
like the mask
quite quite a broadcaster um okay
a couple other people that i want to say
thank you to a new member
signed up with the name teresa rushka
also want to say thanks to ashley
scoggins
and thanks to sir you're in jail
sir you're in jail just signed up very
much appreciate that
that puts us at 97. uh how about a free
a free item from the david pakman show
store for member number
100 why not right i mean we're
celebrating the downfall of
everything that is good with this trump
rally number 100
will get a free item or item
from my store davidpakman.com gear
we'll ship it anywhere in the world
where you can get mail north korea would
be tough is my guess
but let's do it why not let's see
building codes are unnecessary
laughs in florida well said
well said yeah will you cover
massachusetts and hawaii close to 70
percent one shot sure
i will john says disney villains and
comic book villains and south park
characters
are the gop at this point gesh make
says the number of people who turn out
to this to hear this buffoon is
depressing
that's an understatement it's a tragedy
here's a thought experiment tell us your
favorite naughty film
category in the most advertiser friendly
way possible
that seems really boring richard
schaefer
says sir why hasn't sydney powell had
her law license suspended neither
neither she
or rudy should be allowed to practice
law ever i agree
p.s thank you sir
right as we are very very close to
10 000 live viewers
on youtube and
another thousand on twitch
i want to say thanks to crazy but cool
as well as chalice
and dirty curta for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 100
dirty curta you have won a free item
from the david pakman show store if you
would like it just get in touch with me
via email
and things are continuing i want to say
thanks to tanya
sewers as well as taylor orr sherry
ezell has signed up on my website with
the special code
sad trump russell
gabord jose almodovar
has signed up that's seven michelle
o'connor is number eight
hugh thompson is number nine okay
one hundred plus nine nine plus zero is
nine
carry the zero zero plus zero zero one
plus zero that's 109
we're at 109 as we are standing by for
donald trump
does anybody know like is this at an
airport
is trump flying in what's the deal with
it
i don't i don't fully even understand it
okay looks like i guess everybody's
driving in
yeah trump's getting ready certainly
uh okay if someone takes diaper don's
milk
there will be hell to pay anne
says trump won i hope that was worth
five dollars and thank you
david sir what can you tell us about
prageru counterpoints looking forward to
them
please shout out aaron and olive big
fans
yeah no no nothing to announce yet but
working on them
are they just now setting up speakers
it's weird
it's been a long time since i've heard
anything optimistic
from progressive media that i follow
where do you find hope
um not in not in political media
is this rally exclusive to newsmax and
the
right side broadcasting not as far as i
know
is this george papadopoulos what the
hell
depicted blind or where's a blindfold is
because the rule of law is supposed to
be applied equally and fairly
with no regard to political affiliation
or wealth
and that standard was thrown out the
window regarding this targeting by
rudy giuliani rudy giuliani has not been
indicted he's not been convicted of a
crime
yet he has been suspended from
practicing remember that
you know law licenses you don't need to
commit a crime
to lose your law license it's a very
very stupid argument
other super chats coming in been waiting
for trump's car crash speech for hours
now yeah it should be soon
antonio says congratulations to david
hit that like button
uh yeah somehow we've only got 1600
likes despite having 10 thousand viewers
that's that's
honestly i feel like it gives stephen
crowder ammunition against me
dranoa says
i don't know what dranoa says ten
000 viewers and only 1500 likes
smash that button i know i know dranoa
i'm so happy you knew who i was talking
about i also knew you would pronounce my
last name correctly with no problem
quarterwits that's that's easy at this
point
the luck hunters says david flying from
mendoza to boston in 10 days do you need
wine
will any trump org indictment sticks oh
boy
we'll have to deal with that later so
oh my god these super chats are coming
in so quickly i can't keep up
soul reaper says gu toothless
unvaccinated
undereducated ohioans other nt state
just love it when he comes to town
amped help spread t delta variant less
money to bring and trash more fed to
dollar to help people holy [ __ ]
um
looks like the peanut gallery is coming
back marjorie taylor green
jim jordan trump must be speaking soon
the rally is in wellington ohio which is
a nobody cares village and nobody cares
ohio population
less than 5 000.
will you ever write a book and will if
you ever do what would it be about
maybe and i don't know yet
polish finnish says warming up his voice
like a singer
me me me me yeah that's nice it's taking
place between an abandoned grain silo
and an extremely popular niche
pornographic shop
they took guidance from rudy's failed
four seasons debacle i might have to
steal that and tweet it that's good
david are you a marvel fan i am not
jen says hey david sydney australia has
started a two-week lockdown due to the
delta variant covet 19.
thanks for having a live stream it helps
my pleasure
tezi says if trump asked me to pee on
him i would
love the show that's weird and
um i think that gets me caught up
as far as super chats are concerned
i do want to thank a couple of other new
members though
we do have a one day coup today only
guys
we have listen to this 70
off website membership
the code is sad trump
all one word no space
case doesn't matter but just you might
why why capitalize if you don't need to
sad trump i want to say thank you to
stephen farkas
dale elliott carrie holgard
michael debusse as well as trevor boyd
laurie pickhardt susan gold
wow beijing bamboo
micheline beatty kim lorenzen
kyle mahoney larry hall lady blue lady
wow that is crazy that puts us at 118.
we may be pointing towards a record
today
also with the addition of malfunction 99
signing up via twitch putting us at 119.
that's wild
yeah welcome i i'm so glad that the
twitch is holding up
people are saying i may lose my law
license with the coupon code
it's conceivable i may not be allowed to
practice law going forward
let's look at a few other super chats
going to take a shot every time he
claims the election was stolen
i would not do that david it's andrew
from miami looking forward to asking you
a question on the wednesday
show questions are on the friday show
and we're off next week so you're kind
of kind of looking at like
july 8th or something like that probably
it's a great idea to upload more videos
like that right left debate compilation
giving others the opportunity to react
and give you more publicity
yet does anybody know i know destiny
reacted to our left right debate video
did anybody else react that i should be
aware of
because i would want to make sure i give
them some coverage if that's the case
oh i look orange now oh my god i've
gotten completely orange
hold on a second the light is changing
let's see oh my i'm completely orange
let's turn down the hue shift a little
bit
maybe turn down my saturation a hair
wow i am like
whoa should i just do the show green
or blue purple
i might just do this guys
cool okay
um other super chats here
xena says have you heard about the
petition to stop jeff bezos from
returning to earth after a trip to space
i have not heard of that
trump loves to make his base wait in the
hot sun and cold night for hours
um oh come on guys
would you let us watch you urinate for a
hundred million dollars give me a break
give me a break guys all right no but
people don't seem to be loving
me being purple i will change it back
although if somebody can clip this
it would be a cool thing let me see if i
can actually properly set
my hue there i'm red now i'm orange
this is it's going to be tough let me
see
it is bizarre
now i'm like yellow this is crazy
zero
i don't even i might actually have to
just be orange
yellow green i might i don't even know
what color to do
honestly because it just the lighting is
so atrocious
i guess this is as close to natural-ish
as i can do
probably somewhere around here yeah i'm
sorry guys
i think we're gonna have to leave it
here yep
um any good sources for substantive hold
on what was that substantive debate
videos
nah nah not really
why where are you sometimes so green on
videos a few weeks back
i did not i was i was in a remote uh i
was at my remote studio
and i didn't have my settings calibrated
correctly
the record amount of subs is people feel
pity due to your subpar
audio setup you should record everything
in a hotel from now on that's a
that's a pretty good idea i like that
idea
who do you think will win the wefa euro
2021 i
i don't even know i don't know i'm only
watching copa america argentina plays
bolivia monday night
happy to finally get my first vaccine
next week oh this is kyoko kyoko has
called in i believe
you know my country japan is so far
behind in terms of facts
thanks love your show yeah that's great
news kyoko
you're turning violet david what
happened to the newsmax lady's face
i don't know anything but orange purple
skin is a side effect of the vaccine
yeah exactly exactly
yeah i'm looking kind of yellow now but
i don't think i can do much about it
let's listen to what's going on here
well heather you and i were taking
guesses as to who would introduce him
but it's not going to be
any specific person that we know of
because the president landed
after max miller's speech and he's
getting the stage ready right now the
teleprompter is going up and all that
work
so he's coming out around eight o'clock
and the people here are getting
very very anxious they want to hear him
they're on their feet
the music's playing so dude what's going
on is everybody's dehydrated there are
people who have been there 12 hours
these people are fools that's what's
going on
from dolly parton right now i like that
i love it
yeah dolly parton would be disgusted
that this is being played
disgusted super professional stuff says
matt
yeah um david i need your opinion
do you think it's safe to go on vacation
soon if fully vaxxed with the delta
variant or hold off until next year
i asked dr ashish that exact question
last week i
you shouldn't listen to me listen to him
just check the interview
that would be my suggestion on that i
also want to say thank
you there are some really great people
that
i i would be it would be sad if i didn't
thank them um i want to say thank you to
varina weissinger who just signed up
with the code sad
trump justin morrison is a new member
stephanie smith just signed up mary dunn
is a new member paul morrison and
janet varan angry lame duck
as well as carrie evans nicholas small
mike wilson elizabeth napoli is a new
member
holger nelke as well as marjorie taylor
green
have signed up thank you also to logan
kemp
erika claussen and doug herbert can't
forget to thank aisha
overseth ben fitzpatrick
eric rumpf oh hold on a second
eric rumpf i think i know who that is
oh maybe not okay no i know someone with
the same name okay
well again that that's already a lot um
that's 13 putting us at 132.
uh did i get everybody i hope i did
let me just see
um yes steven farkas was the previous
one very good okay
all right we're caught up guys i
apologize i'm doing my best to keep up
with everything that's going on here
uh and also on twitch
i want to say thank you to
uh oh oobleck ooze
for the twitch prime sub over on twitch
appreciate that
very much so okay let's see if we can
hear just a couple of other super chats
before
uh trump comes out mao zeding dong
infesting my home state sir your
followers
if your followers were to throw you a
rally what song would you walk out to oh
man
maybe fool in the rain by led zeppelin
thoughts on the absolute parody that was
dave rubin's interview with
donald trump yesterday did you see it no
is that true
dave rubin interviewed don jr or donald
trump that i have to see
nobody knows
was it just a joke
wow huh
yeah i mean that i i'm not going to pull
it up right now but
junior some people are saying it was
junior
okay well whoever it was oh he did a
phone interview with donald trump not
junior oh my god
that sounds insane let's see uh
ruben report youtube
see if i can find this real quick that
sounds
reuben actually texted me a few weeks
ago
don't really want to go into it right
now but
let's see what we can find
let's take a look at this yeah just
while we're waiting for trump here
let's see what we got
i do not have my ad blocker here
all right guys big day around here i'm
about to interview
president donald j trump we are doing a
sit-down
although it's a slightly different
sit-down because he is doing it
via the phone the the classic style of
interviewing
uh from an undisclosed location but
before we start i want to say one thing
which is that his team made it very
okay but i did a couple of them today i
like because i'm not
confined as to uh number of characters
but you know the number of characters
you don't want to keep it too long
anyway
okay that's one thing we all learned
maybe from that no i
i think uh i think we're doing very well
with that being said i'll be on social
media in the not too distant future
we're looking at a lot of options we had
strong hundreds of millions of people
you know if you look at uh
we had 91 on one site we had 10 and
another we had 36 on another we had
potus
we have imagine being dave rubin and
going from like hey i think bernie's
ideas are pretty good
to i am now a trump supporter people on
facebook
and i i hear it's become very boring to
be honest and i hear in particular
twitter has become very very boring
a lot of conservative voices have gotten
off some have been thrown out and a lot
of them have gotten off
and i hear twitter is not doing well and
it's lost his voice
and when i started there like 11 or 12
years ago
it was not a success i mean it was not a
i don't know it was going to make it but
it was not a success it became
very successful and i think you're going
to see a lot of people are going to be
finding other
other there's a lot of platforms out
there that's what we're looking at
what a boring conversation huh getting
the right platform a perfect platform
and i think uh you'll see something
fairly soon
yeah that's great to hear and as as you
may know i've been talking to
to some of your guys about locals.com
which is the tech company i started so
we shall see
good uh so you know why did locals.com
what on earth what is he talking about
what is that
i've never even heard of that is anyone
on that
told my audience many times that one of
the reasons that i
did i didn't support you in 2016 but
then i did
all right it looks like trump's coming
here uh let's see what's going on here
to be
so involved with uh larry kudlow on the
economy
uh other yeah there is different issues
yeah is that him i think
all right let's see who i can thank real
quick before uh this all gets going if i
can get a few last thank yous and trump
wearing a ridiculous
walking with a ridiculous hat let me say
thank you to
i know there's a few people i i'm going
to fall behind here sylvia de montine
christine kohler ringo huge
okay i think that's it thanks to all
three of you uh here is trump
let's see what he has to say we stream
stuff all the time people are asking do
i ever stream
um yeah i'm i'm streaming all the time
just follow the channel
subscribe free follow on twitch whatever
you'll be notified
let's see what's happening are they
playing that stupid country song let's
see
they're playing reagan so we'll see what
happens
with his speech tonight we expect he'll
go about an hour but as we mentioned
maybe he'll go a little bit longer
because
he was a little late to take the stage
now if you're late you go shorter
because people are already exhausted
max miller for congress
and i think that we're going to pause
now
and take the former president of the
united states they're live from the
fairgrounds in
lorraine county wellington ohio
have a good night everybody
dear god thanks to count shane for the
twitch sub i appreciate that
uh yeah this is bringing this is like
traumatic this is i think we're getting
re-traumatized by this nonsense to some
degree
um i will keep seeing yeah the the
membership counter will keep ticking up
don't
don't worry about that
[Music]
can you imagine
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the that's the commonly the
favorite song of rich dudes from queens
they all love that song they just can't
get enough
well i want to thank ohio for the
incredible thousands of people trying to
get in
and all of the unbelievable hard-working
patriots who are here tonight
at the very first rally of the 2022
election we're going to take back the
house we're going to take back the
senate
so that's what this is about okay
with your help we are going to defeat
the radical democrats
and we have no choice you know that
right we have no choice
and we're going to elect an amazing
slate of
proud american first republicans next
year america first
you never used to hear that expression
did you you hear it plenty now
after just five months the biden
administration is already a
complete and total catastrophe
[Laughter]
i told you oh man crime is surging
murders are soaring police departments
are being
gutted illegal aliens are
overrunning their borders nobody's ever
seen anything like it
our poor borders they were so perfect
they were poor
drug cartels and human traffickers are
back in business like they've never been
before they're doing
numbers that they've never even thought
possible
record just a few short months ago drugs
were way down human trafficking was way
down
it was all way down it was all they had
to do is go away for a little while it
was beautiful
but the schools when you take a look at
schools
and you look at all of the things that
happen left
wing indoctrination camps
critical race fearing is being forced
on our military you guys were right
you guys predicted crt would be brought
up it was brought up within what we're
about a minute in
humiliating our country
joe biden is destroying our nation right
before our very own eyes
the number one priority for everyone who
wants to save america is to pour
every single ounce of energy you have
into winning a gigantic victory
in the midterms and in 2024
right
[Applause]
together we will send joe biden and the
fake news media there's a lot of people
back there look at that
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that does he have no new
material
do you miss me they miss me turn the
cameras around
hey mister i know
they look at their bad ratings and
they're saying we miss this guy
i said it was gonna happen i was waiting
for them to endorse me actually
i know that was a big step but they're
going down the tubes their numbers are
very bad
but together we will send biden and the
media and all of the people that are so
bad to our country big tech tyrants
a message they cannot ever censor
cancel or ignore we will take back
the house we will take back the senate
and we will take
back america and we will do it remember
he makes no mention of the fact that
they lost all those things because of
him
that's not mentioned but now they're
going to take it back there is no more
dire
threat today than the crisis on our
southern border
other than perhaps our elections that's
a dire threat to
that's probably the biggest threat of
all isn't it huh what happened in the
election it's a disgrace
but we'll be talking about that unless
you'd rather not
have me talk about it would you rather
talk about it
immediately upon taking office joe biden
deliberately and systematically through
his
people because i don't think he did it
dismantled america's border defenses
and so that's the biden dementia
reference we predicted that one too but
we i mean you guys i didn't do anything
special you guys said he's gonna talk
about it and he did
laws from every single corner of the
globe they were invited
in and we can't do that we can't afford
it
we can't have it we can't have people
coming out of prisons we have no idea
who they are
illegal border crossings are now up
976
since just a short few months ago
when i left office we gave the new
administration
the most secure southern border our
country
had ever seen by far
we ended the ridiculous catch and
relation or that is
you catch him and you release them into
our country a brilliant policy
and they're back at that now we ended
asylum fraud
we built almost 500 miles of very
beautiful
very successful wall that was working
and it wouldn't oh thank you
that's a friend of mine he's a conductor
what a beautiful sound by the way i have
to say
you know i have to say just driving over
here was a 30 minute drive from the
airport
the farms the houses the lawns are all
beautiful
it looks like you cut your lawns every
day
you have no crime you have no murders
you have no plugins
i said to a couple of the law
enforcement people who are phenomenal
by the way
one of the crime stats here let me guess
there's not a lot of it
he said sir there isn't but sir was so
beautiful every farm was perfect the
barns
that's sir routine it's so stupid every
time like it's it's like
it it's like the first time all over
again on november 3rd
the great state of ohio in a record
a record number a record novel
we want a lot of places that people
haven't figured out yet but
actually most of them have we empowered
ice
to do their jobs we
worked to you guys notice that right
places people haven't figured out yet
but actually most of them have
oh okay why'd you mention it sanctuary
cities
sanctuary cities take care of many many
criminals they're very dangerous places
even in california they really want
sanctuary cities out
but for some reason the politicians
don't didn't they send out
38 million ballots in
california i wonder what the real vote
in california with me
[Music]
and we crushed the very vicious thugs
i mean that's genuinely nuts that's
something um
i think mike pillow floated that trump
actually won california
it's like dude if you're gonna claim you
won don't claim you won california
and we rapidly threw them the hell out
of our country
and we did it by the thousands blew them
and once we got the word out people
didn't come it wasn't really that big a
deal
and people just didn't come once he came
in he said we want everybody to come in
oh that was a disaster
you have by the way not the numbers they
report remember they're fake news
you have millions of people coming into
this country
you have millions of people coming my
guess is most of the news he's pointing
to are right-wing media like
i i is is mainstream media even covering
this does anybody know policy is to make
illegal immigration as easy as possible
instituting catch and release ripping
apart our
asylum agreements ordering a stop and
like did you see this a stop any
contractors here do you ever get a stop
that was a glitch i think stop order the
world has ever seen
we stopped finishing the wall we stopped
working on the wall
now they want to finish the wall and the
contractors are saying how much are you
going to pay
us they have to start all over again
congratulate those contractors they're
going to make a fortune
they crippled ice and the border patrol
i'll tell you what border patrol
these are incredible people ice they're
incredible people i wouldn't want the
job
i wouldn't want it most of the people
you have some very tough people in this
audience i can't see
anybody that would do that shot very
well let me just say
it's a rough job they run into a pack
they call it a pack
they run into a pack of ms-13 and they
start swinging and they start swinging
hard
and in the end they win they're tough
they're smart and you know what they
love our country
and somebody has to do that work for the
last three months
more than anything that you've ever seen
the illegal alien miners have arrived at
our border these are
in many just wonderful kids right
they are coming in at levels that we've
never seen and then they're sent around
all over this country all over the
country they're sent
he's really painting a very clear
picture where anybody could understand
exactly what he means right time they're
on suicide watch
so many of these young kids they're in
suicide watch all because of this stupid
policy
that you've been watching over the last
few months kids are on suicide watch
think of that
biden has violated his constitutional
oath
endangered our safety and look he
surrendered our
our really if you think of it no matter
how you cover it
sovereignty what he's done to our nation
is unthinkable in a short period of time
and i said that was going to happen
i said it was going to happen if people
need mercy bans just ask the moderators
on twitch and youtube they'll they can
start banning people if you just need
mercy bands we can do it the lawless
agenda
we have to defund his reckless
immigration policies and restore our
nation's
southern border to where it was
oh
illness sad though
in many cases undiagnosed in almost all
cases
certainly untreated did you ever hear
the expression that the
vote counter is sometimes much more
important
than the candidate did you ever hear
that expression uh-oh
think about that because what happened
on november 3rd
was a disgrace on the evening of
november
3rd you lost the election was over yes
and then all of a sudden things started
closing down all over
will he say dumps will he say dumpster
didn't happen in ohio but it happened in
certain swing states
and we took a massive
victory they did into something that
should never be allowed kamala harris
kamala give me a break dude
[Applause]
is it common that former presidents
can't correctly say the names of the
current president
and or vice president is that common
because i announced that i was going
next week and i
am at the request of
texas governor abbott and the border
patrol i'm going to the border next week
oh if i didn't do that i don't know if
she was ever going to go i really don't
know if that
was she ever going to go i don't know
the radical
[Music]
open border fanaticism
call it whatever you want is also
contributing to massive crime
other countries are emptying their
prisons into the united states you know
that right right
they're emptying they're opening their
prisons why should they have these
killers these
drug dealers these traffickers are they
trafficking women
by the way mostly like trump right i
mean what's trump's specialty
why should they feed them why should
they have to watch them and they're very
dangerous
let's send them to the united states
we'll put them in the caravans and
they'll get in because nobody even
checks who's coming into our country
it's insanity and it's destroying our
country destroying our country the
really crazy thing here
is thinking anything really could have
changed that dramatically one way or the
other
in just a few months like that whatever
side you're on
falling for that is really the lie
murder and
many other things gunned down a man
in broad daylight shooting him
viciously and violently as he lay in the
street four times
recently in louisiana great place
an illegal alien who entered the country
as an unaccompanied minor
under obama was charged with hacking a
woman
and their 15 year old sister into very
small pieces
with a machete piece stabbing two other
people
dear god and right here in ohio
a twice deported fugitive ms-13 gang
member the worst
anywhere in the world and we've taken
out
thousands and thousands and now they
want to let them come back
he was charged with murder he was
discovered
in galloway after entering our country
for a third time and bad things happened
and you know when i came up tonight i
had so many people they said could you
do us a favor what
could you talk the snake you remember
the snake
they said sir tell the snakes does
anybody want to hear the snake
you want to hear it oh no not this poem
this is people who know nothing about
literature
being read a poem by a guy who knows
nothing about literature meant to be
for the border it was meant to be for
other reasons but this has to be
really what's happening to our border
and so many people said please please
you're going to ohio i don't know the
fact that i'm going to ohio why they
want to talk about the snake
well the story is made up it makes no
sense it's a totally made up story
it's because of the borders and because
ohio sees it
far better than most don't you you
understand what's happening
the snake on her way to work one morning
down the path along the lake a tender
hearted woman sorry poor
sorry this is so stupid guys that i
sort of can't take it but i'll read a
couple super chats while he does this
trump's lies are up 976 percent it's
disgusting
i say kamala the same way wwe did
aloha david do you think this rally may
cause more violence why is he in ohio
i couldn't i guess because of maxim is
he in ohio because of max miller is that
what's going on
trump's alliteration is similar to
hitler's no joke
um yeah this this is all insane
uh and i'm glad people people are
pointing it out uh
big thank you to randall pomeroy sylvia
de montine
we do have a one day coupon code because
this is also disgusting and sad the
coupon code sad
trump saves you 70 on my website that's
the number you see above my head 140
people have taken advantage of it
and part of the reason they're doing it
is that this [ __ ] is really sad listen
she clutched him to her bosom bosom
you're so beautiful
she cried but if i hadn't brought you in
by now
you truly would have died she stroked
his pretty skin again
and kissed him and held him tight
but instead of saying thank you
the snake gave her a vicious bite
take me no tender woman take me in for
heaven's sake take me and hotend a woman
seems like
like the third grade reading level type
stuff like you'd analyzes in third grade
cried the woman and you've bitten me but
why
you know your bite is poisonous and now
i'm going to die
shut up silly woman
said the reptile you can tell this is a
crowd that really
loves poetry snake before you
took me in
[Music]
it's the way it is these are the types
of folks who would cheer because they
think trump
invented poetry like they think he's
brilliant they're like that's incredible
this guy just
invented like the spoken word poetry
it's like no no no he read a poem guys
horrible people good people are coming
in but horrible horrible
people again remember that term they're
emptying their prisons and
you know if you were heading those
countries guatemala
honduras el salvador and many others
including middle eastern countries by
the way
that's how they come out no evidence the
snake
in the republican party we do not
believe that violent criminals should be
welcomed into our country with open arms
we believe that they should be
promptly deported or put behind bars and
that's what i did during my
administration
at a level that nobody's ever seen
the radical left democrats are doing
everything possible to put your family
in grave danger i don't know if they're
doing it out of
naivete or are they doing it because
they think it's really
good to have all these people coming
into our country
but they are putting your family into a
very very bad position
releasing criminal aliens defunding the
police
abolishing cash bail look at new york
what's happened to our poor new york
crime is through the roof i would love
for trump to address some of the
threats or fear-mongering of his
campaign where he said like
if biden's president you'll have to
flush 10 to 15 times
is that happening if biden's president
your 401k will be worth nothing did that
happen like address some of that stuff
los angeles they have great police
forces they're not allowed to do their
job and now they're all leaving
that's going to be a real problem when
they realize we need them to help us
and they're not going to be there any
longer
they all try and take away your guns and
that's what they're doing and if you
remember when i was campaigning against
joe biden i said they're going to take
away your guns your second amendment is
under siege in chicago
which is the single most dangerous city
large scale
has the strongest gun laws in the
country
they even say the strongest gun laws in
the world and yet
people are being shot by the thousands
every year worse than afghanistan how
about that
worse than afghanistan where by the way
i started that's pretty dumb since all
the troops are coming back home they
couldn't stop the press
21 years is enough don't we think 21.
remember that that's not true uh biden
when he got into office
paused everything trump trump was doing
to review it
uh and then decided to continue with it
it's uh
trump's framing of it is a total lie by
a government that
wouldn't last the only way they last is
if we're there
what are we going to say we'll stay for
another 21 years and we'll stay for
another 50. the whole thing is
ridiculous so we're bringing our troops
back home from iraq
we're bringing troops back home from
afghanistan that's right
biden is doing this trump's just saying
he's doing it against the troops we had
on the border with syria remember that
we had thousands of troops between
turkey and syria i say wait a minute
this border's been here for a thousand
years plus
we never did anything now why are we
doing it sir you can't do it it'll be
war
i said our troops are in grave danger
you have two armies
and you have our troops in the middle so
i started bringing them home
and then we got down to 54 troops and i
said to one of the generals who was that
good general he wasn't awoke general do
you notice the woke generals we have
talking about mark milly there this was
a real general
i said we have 54 men from 5 000. we
have 54 men on the board are they in
danger
said sir you have 54 men between two
armies
they don't have a chance how many stairs
are we up to practice i said get him the
hell out
and everybody said what a terrible thing
he did and you know what that was three
years ago
and nothing happened they protect their
own borders pretty amazing right
pretty amazing but you'll never hear
that from the fake news
or many other things that turned out to
be right if you care about
the security of your family if you care
about the safety of your
community if you care about law and auto
look law and order in the great state of
ohio but it said law and auto like
auto insurance people outside they're
like incredible people
they're patriots
they're patriots one of them came out
and i shouldn't say this but
you know look i met so many but one of
them came out there's tears in his eyes
this guy
hasn't cried in a very long time
but just in meeting because i represent
what
they want they want law and they want
order
and that's what you want you guys
getting that
so you have to deliver massive
majorities for republicans in congress
next year have to do it right here in
ohio's
16th congressional district you have the
opportunity to elect
an incredible patriot to congress who i
know very well
he grew up in this area believe it or
not he's not a carpetbagger like so many
a lot of them say sir i'm running for
congress oh good how long have you lived
there well actually i moved there last
week
it's beyond parody now i mean max miller
you know max
great guy he loves our country he loves
the people of ohio
and max was a trusted of mine in the
white house we had great people working
for me we had some real
losers too by the way but yeah which
happened when
i didn't know too many people you know
in washington i was there 17 times a
month i thought he was all about hiring
the right people
in the united states so we made a couple
but do i know the people
do i know the good ones i know the good
ones but we had some really great people
and max was one of them he did a
fantastic job
he helped me with north korea
negotiation and
we did so much for israel and iraq and
the g7
g20 we brought peace to the middle east
if this guy would finish it
but now he's going back to the iran
trump but brought peace between
countries that were not in conflict or
more likely in congress max will be
tough on illegal immigration he will be
strong on crime as strong as you can get
he will stand up to china and he will
protect
ohio jobs just like i did remember in
lima do you remember they were going to
close your tank plan
and i was president-elect i didn't know
anything about the tank plant but i
heard
through a great gentleman did anybody
ever hear of a man named jim
jordan
you know i have yeah
a lot of college wrestlers unfortunately
have heard of him as well
as they wanted to wrestle jim and they
got their ass kicked every time
he hasn't changed but jim told me about
jim's here by the way so
i'll introduce him in a couple of
minutes but
but they wanted to close a tank plant
and i went to see it
lima i went to see it and
i couldn't believe big massive plant the
people that worked there were so
talented
they have the turrets i mean the only
thing you know about texas is dukakis
right where he walked with the helmet
helmet he wouldn't have looked good in
this tank either
but you know i see these tanks and i
said to the guys who's going to make
these this is the only place
it's it's actually very interesting
because the crowd
is extremely gullible in that they
follow
trump wherever he goes and cheer boo
anything
but they also are kind of bored like
they also don't really it's more the
idea of being here
that now that it started many of them
seem kind of checked out
and i i ended that order it was a stupid
order i ended it
and we now have that plant working
overtime making tanks and tanks and
tanks
[Applause]
i mean you wouldn't have a tank and
believe it or not
tanks are very important max's opponent
is a guy named anthony gonzalez who's
bad news he's a grandstanding rhino
not respected in dc who voted for
the unhinged unconstitutional illegal
impeachment witch hunt the witch hunt
you know this guy used to call me and
my people in the office which said you
know somebody named gonzalez i said no
he's a congressman from ohio and he said
so what would tell me about him what's
that they said search
to go to ohio in air force one because i
was coming to iowa i came to ohio a lot
okay i feel very comfortable i used to
work in ohio
i used to work in cincinnati ohio i love
the queen city cincinnati but he wanted
to know if he could fly on air force one
you know with all the people in congress
i think he was just about the only guy
he heard i was going to uh could he fly
back and forth in air force one i said
i don't know who's the guy tell me about
him and i didn't hear much good
but i said what the hell he's asking so
let him ride you know it holds like 400
people
so you put a guy in a seat right
and i don't get to know him too well but
i'd see him on the plane and then i'd
see him go back and then i'd be going
three months later and he'd call again
could i go to ohio on air force one i
put him on the plane
is any story where trump says sir a
story that never happened is that the is
that the signal
it was impeachment i don't know
that's that's not the reason i'm doing
this but i just thought it's a
it's a character trait that was not so
good not so good now he's a
he's a sellout he's a fake republican
and a disgrace to your state i will tell
you that
and he's not the candidate that you want
representing the republican party he's
the
candidate of liz cheney that's another
beauty listen
mitt romney do you notice you notice
the democrats have horrible policy right
to fund the police
open borders sanctuary cities all of the
canceled culture let's cancel out george
washington you see that
they're after george washington now
right they said i did say two years ago
they may go there if you're not strong
they're gonna go there but
he's a candidate he works he likes liz
cheney mitt romney nancy pelosi
joe bide earlier this year gonzalez
voted to
grant amnesty to illegal aliens okay
i thought we were trying to go the
opposite way so that we can
have our country back and have our
borders back he voted to keep our
soups i see so this is like a trial
balloon
this is basically can trump succeed in
uh pushing um you know an anti like
it's not even really anti-trump not
pro-trump enough congressman
republican out and if this works then
this is what we're going to see from now
until 2022
there's an ex exploratory vibes green
man exactly right
hanging in there you know every single
republican needs to vote
him out of office and nominate and vote
for
a really great guy max miller a passion
he's got a passion for this country like
you wouldn't believe
max come on up and say hello this is
your territory
max miller
now even pre-covered trump didn't like
touching people so let's see what
happens here
okay a little slap on the back then
that's your for the 45th president of
the united states
donald j trump i don't know whose
diction is worse trump's or this guy
that's right
and come 2024 we're gonna get him
elected for the third time
that's right
there is no greater fighter that this
country has ever had
and i have never had a greater role
model than president donald j
trump period for none
i need all of your help to get rhino
turn code tony out of office and to help
put an america first
conservative into office for the 16th
district
i have to tell you in a sense
republicans fighting republicans if
trump's energy goes to that it's sort of
good but obviously that'll change as we
get closer to the actual midterm
great guy i can tell you he's a great
guy
also with us another outstanding
candidate for congress he's right now i
just saw a poll
max is doing great and he's doing great
and his race is very soon
he's filling his seat and i think he's
going to win he's going to win big i see
there's like 12 candidates and we
endorsed him a couple of weeks ago and
now he's
leading by a lot and he's a wonderful
man i've known him for a long time
mike carey mike where are you mike where
is mike
come here mike come here
don't keep them long mike but say hello
so august 3rd right by august 3rd you're
running right
so that's sooner than max
mike you gotta win mike yes sir
thank you mr president thank all of you
with his endorsement
the america first agenda we are now
leading by double digits
thank you mr president thank all of you
and god bless america
man these guys just don't seem to be all
there is
is it just me who's seeing that what do
you think
doing this and uh it's gonna be a big
winner
both of these people this is what we
need we're also thrilled to be joined by
a person who's actually loved you don't
necessarily hear that but she's loved
and respected and she's tough and smart
and kind
by who and kind and she's got such
great common sense representative
marjorie taylor green
yikes
she left
she's a fighter she's a fighter and
another one
we just mentioned his name but i'll
mention it again come up here jim jordan
come up
this should be a rare treat
this guy you are so lucky to have him in
ohio that's all i can say
trump and jim jordan may actually
wrestle right now just to show how
everything's on the up and up
well thank you mr president they've
already heard from me they want to hear
from you
mostly what they want is for you to run
in 2024 and go back to the white house
thank you all very much
[Applause]
this has like a sort of um the king's
court sort of like um
saudi royal family welcoming
line where everybody just gets their
shot at sucking up to trump to then
later get something you know
well they said you got to see this guy
working out you know they work out
they're not in good shape they never
were they were never athletes or
anything and he was a
uh champion ncaa champ he was uh one of
the ncaa
he works out and they say you wouldn't
believe this guy he burns out the
machines the machines are
catching they're like burning out
they're smoking but you know the reason
when jim jordan does when jim jordan
weight lifts the machines combust and
they've got to call in the firefighters
exactly trump's super impressed with jim
jordan's physique
me i'd rather wear a jacket most of you
i think would rather work
but he's a great person he's tough and
he's smart and he's delusional
yeah incredible so thank you both and
marjorie thank you very much for being
here we appreciate it thank you
north dakota governor christie gnome
who's been
terrific where is christopher thank you
christy
you're doing a great job
the heroes that these people have is is
concerning two years ago she said sir do
you think we could have fireworks at the
mag never happened sir those magnificent
faces i love those faces do you think my
face will ever be that or though
they all said he wants it now let's
leave it the way it is
but she called couldn't we have
fireworks right and i said
what's the problem they won't approve it
the democrats they wouldn't approve for
years and years and years
i said is there anything that can burn
no you know stone
i said what's the problem they just
won't give it so we gave it and we had
a night to remember right remember that
that was something perfect
evening and the democrats just announced
that they're canceling it for the people
of
south dakota they're canceling it i i
don't know you know
they're cancelling it so you have some
other alternatives but nothing could be
like those nights right nothing could be
like those nights it was so beautiful
beautifully so beautiful and they will
not cancel
that particular slab that is so
beautiful so incredible
you know they were talking about let's
take it down you know they're like
they're talking about thomas jefferson
they want to take it down
we stopped that we stopped that but uh
these people
they're sickos there's no question about
it there's a lot of sickness there so
christy thank you very much for being
here
also appreciate it and we'll get the
fireworks back
we'll get those fireworks back okay
great mount rushmore county
commissioners
michelle hung and david
moore and my friend jj
and jen cafaro great people
they're great thank you thank you
everybody thank you jj for being here
thank you some high risk reading going
on
our movement achieved more than anyone
thought possible there's never been
anything like it we passed
record-setting tax cuts massive
regulation cuts which i think were even
more important than tax cuts
in terms of the economy that's what gave
us that incredible base
that they're destroying slowly but it
create it was so strong
it has some momentum regulation cuts
again nobody's ever seen anything and
achieved
american energy independence which by
next
month will be gone i still don't
actually know what he means when he says
that
i i've not figured out what he means by
that
we ended up i know it's a lie what i'm
saying is i'm i'm just not understanding
all of the ways in which it's lie big
partnership
would have destroyed your businesses in
ohio and elsewhere
he doesn't know either fair brand new
and unbelievably successful
you know why i knew it was good because
canada didn't want to
canada didn't want it mexico didn't want
it either
president of mexico by the way great
person great man great guy he's doing a
good job
but we did the usmca defending ohio
steel workers and standing up to china
like never before you wouldn't have a
steel industry if i didn't do what we
did you would not have they were dumping
steel all over the place
huge dumps of steel including making
them pay
tens of billions of dollars for the
privilege of doing business
in the usa they have to pay tens of they
never gave us 10 cents
and now they're paying tens of billions
but biden wants to end that
you want to see china take off take off
those tariffs okay take off the
taxes that we charged him when the virus
arrived
man he still doesn't get the american
companies pay the tariffs it's crazy
and they said it would take three years
to five years we got it done in less
than nine months
record record record time
and we launched the fastest economic
recovery
anyone has ever seen we really built the
economy twice if you think about it
we built it twice we set joe biden up
so beautifully all he had to do is go to
the beach joe go to the beach
would have been so good instead biden is
going to drive
our economy and our country into ruin
biden canceled the american keystone
trump's going to have a toilet brought
up and he's going to flush it for us
just so we can see how bad
indoor plumbing's gotten under joe biden
but he approved the russian pipeline to
europe that's great
remember they said oh trump isn't tough
on russia really i stopped the pipeline
to
europe i sanctioned them all over the
place and i had a good relationship with
putin but that's a good thing that's not
a bad thing that's a good thing
you know that's not bad view that is
good
and frankly i had a great relationship
also with president xi
of china until we got hit with the virus
and then i couldn't look at him
quite the same way right you can
understand that and we made a great
trade deal that's helping the
manufacturers and the farmers like
never before farmers have never done
better because china is
living up to that trade deal because
they really sort of have to
it's a tough deal crowd on the edge of
their seat a lot of people are
benefiting
and if you look at north korea right kim
jungle and
all of a sudden he's talking not nice
and he was talking very nice i got along
with him i get along with everybody
eventually
eventually sometimes it just takes a
little bit longer but you know getting
along with
these people that's a good thing
remember president obama said we're
going to war with north korea he said
it's virtually inevitable we didn't go
to war with north korea
we didn't go to war and we don't want to
go to war with north korea
9 000 miles away we didn't want to go
he's acting like he's still in charge of
anything it's really weird
even to this day is a very good
relationship and that is a good thing
and there are some i don't like to
some of them that take advantage of us
that you wouldn't even think
canada was very tough in the united
states in trade for a long time until we
came along
other countries in europe you take a
look at what they do we protect
them militarily but they're very very
tough on us on trade how many chevrolets
are sold in berlin
i asked and they said oh we don't
believe any i said that's exactly right
no no yeah that has more to do with the
fact that germany's got some pretty good
cars
uh it's a very weird
yeah anyway i'm not even gonna get into
that i owe oil and gas
devastate and close large numbers of
countries it's a it's trillions of
dollars of damage is going to be done i
ended it
and i couldn't believe it i said this is
going to be a tough day um and because
it's such a nice
name the paris environmental accord how
nice is that right
and i ended it i said i'm going to get
killed everybody loved it when i entered
it
everybody loved it but we have to pay
trillions he put us immediately back
without even negotiating just the same
horrible deal
you know china doesn't kick in for many
years russia doesn't
kick in yeah it's like there are trade
considerations but
you know how many germans are sitting
around going
you know we've got volkswagen we've got
bmw we've got merced we have all these
great
uh we need like a chevy let's just i
really want to buy a chevy bring
chevy's over on the other hand how many
americans are saying
you know i don't know i went to the
chevy dealership i didn't see something
that was that great
i went to bmw and i'm liking it that
that's that's 90 of it and we rebuilt
our military and we did so much
we did so even right to try i always
mentioned you know many people are being
saved with right to try the fda
is slow as hell i wouldn't say they love
me too much i push them very hard
but now if people are all right guys i'm
at my limit i am on uh um
a schedule i've got to go to a dinner um
trump started over an hour late so it's
been great to be with you guys
to the extent that i was able to be feel
free to watch the rambling on your own
or not also or not also our